-You know
our first guest tonight
from films like "300"
and "Olympus Has Fallen."
He stars in "Hunter Killer,"
which is in theaters Friday.
Let's take a look.
-75! 50 feet!
40 feet!
-Cast it!
-30 feet! 2-5!
-Terminal holding, Captain.
-Right full rudder.
-Right full rudder,
aye, Captain.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Gerard Butler,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Welcome back.
I'm so happy to have you here.
I think you're living the dream.
I feel like, if you're an actor
who at some point in your career
gets to scream "right full
rudder," that's the dream.
-I actually had a --
I was in a Bond movie
right at the beginning
of my career,
and I got to say things like --
I was a sailor on a ship saying,
"Torpedoes bearing range,
6,000."
And while I'm filming,
the quartermaster said
he wouldn't say that.
So it all got taken away
from me.
-Oh, he took away your lines.
-He took away my lines.
And I was left with,
"We're down by the stern, sir."
So from that day, I said,
"I am making a submarine movie.
I'm going to produce it
and nobody is going to take
my lines away."
-There you go.
You play a captain
in this movie.
And there's a coup in Russia.
And you're sort of preventing
a world war.
Normal stuff for Gerard Butler.
-Normal stuff. Yeah.
-A regular day at the office.
But this is interesting.
The Pentagon, the Navy asked you
to actually
give a press conference
to talk about the film.
And this is a real thing.
You went and gave a press
conference at the Pentagon.
And I should point out --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Like, you're -- so this --
I want to make sure
everybody knows.
You're an actor
talking about a movie.
But these are real reporters.
Right?
-Yes. Yes.
-How was it?
-Unfortunately they put in the
real reporters, not fake ones.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, so the Navy were
incredible in supporting us
with this movie, and then I was
invited to the Pentagon.
I thought,
"Great, I'm going to go along,
get a trip around the Pentagon
and they're going to
show me around."
And they said, "And if you can
just do a press conference
at the end."
And they gave me information
about the Navy.
So I'm thinking -- I'm more
defending them, saying,
"Don't worry, you didn't spend
any money,
necessarily deviate
from their missions."
And as we get there, I look out,
and I go,
"I recognize this room, though."
And then I walk out and I look
behind me and I'm --
That's the Pentagon sign.
I'm actually doing a --
and I see Barbara Starr of CNN
and the first question
is Saudi Arabia.
-Oh, boy.
-The second question is, "How do
you solve Saudi Arabia?"
I'm like, "Okay, I don't know.
Did we get the same memo?"
[ Laughter ]
Because, I didn't --
[ Applause ]
And it was 32 minutes.
-Wow!
-32 minutes at the Pentagon.
And I still didn't quite
appreciate it until afterwards
when I saw photos and it's me
standing in front of the panel.
I know that sounds stupid, but I
really didn't appreciate it
until I see the photos and go,
"No, I was actually doing
a press conference."
-I just like to think of
an editor saying,
"Who gave these quotes?"
And they were like,
"It was Gerard Butler today."
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah.
There was even
a headline saying --
I saw it after, but it said,
"Gerard Butler speaks live from
the Pentagon in a few minutes."
And you go, "That's -- I see
that with Trump, I see that,
but Gerard Butler speaks live"?
Like, what's he got to say?
-I will say, like,
five years ago,
that crawl on CNN
I would think is weird.
Now anything, I'm like,
whatever.
-That's true. That's true.
-That's not crazier
than anything else.
[ Applause ]
Did you actually go --
You went out on a submarine
just to do a little research.
-Yeah. I went out with the
director, Donovan Marsh.
Went out on this --
it was one of the most,
maybe the most incredible
experiences I ever had
going out for three days
underway from Pearl Harbor.
And we did all the maneuvers
that we do in the movie.
So battle stations
and deep dives
and fire drills, et cetera.
But when we first went out --
one of the drills
they do is man overboard.
But they do man overboard.
They're not going to throw a man
overboard every time,
so they throw a bag of popcorn.
-Yeah, right.
-Into the ocean, right?
-That's far more disposable.
-Yeah, yeah.
And then they spend
the next four minutes
trying to rescue this popcorn
from the ocean.
[ Laughter ]
This 8,000-ton sub that stops,
maneuvers back, forward,
and then somebody climbs out of
the hatch
and dives into the water
and grabs the popcorn
before, hopefully, it bursts.
-I feel like if a boat
was going by and saw that,
they would just think, "I can't
believe that's the only popcorn
they have on that submarine."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we did eat that popcorn.
Yeah, we dried it out in the
microwave and then we had it.
And then the captain also lit up
a cigar before we went out.
He was like, "Okay, this is
what we're going to do."
So we lit up a cigar.
I'm thinking, "This is insane."
I'm on top of
a hunter killer submarine
and feeling a bit queasy,
though, and all I hear is --
[ Grunting ]
And I turn around and I'm
looking at the captain, like,
"Is that Donovan?"
And Donovan is over the back,
throwing up.
-That's your director?
-Our director, Donovan,
is throwing up
on the edge of the tower.
Gone was that hope that we could
pretend to be
bad-ass movie people.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I would say you played right
into the stereotype
that the Navy had of you, yeah.